you were told that austerity and
inequality bankers bonuses and tuition
fees were inevitable they were not you
all deserve better
let's put principles and values first
that's why I got into politics the Green
Party is determined to deliver a fair
economy that does not make the poor and
disadvantaged pay for the errors and
fraud of the bankers we're committed to
returning the NHS to its founding
principles no public money going in to
private profits we know we must take
real action on climate change the
biggest threat facing us all other
parties trade in fear fear of immigrants
demonizing people on benefits but to
build a decent Humane Society we start
with hope vote for change vote green
Natalie Bennett thank you and now we go
tonight and Faraj there are six other
party leaders on this platform tonight
they may all look different but actually
on some of the big issues that affect
this country they're very much the same
all six of them support Britain's
membership of the European Union and
most of our laws being made somewhere
else and as a consequence of that all of
them support open-door immigration is it
any wonder the trust in politics has
broken down to the extent that it has
well I represent UK and we believe in
Britain and we believe this country
should be a self-governing nation we
believe we're good enough to do that and
we also believe that open-door
immigration has depressed the wages for
ordinary people made buying houses for
youngsters very difficult made it tough
to get a GP appointment and not been
good for this country we have a positive
alternative let's have a trade deal with
Europe let's cooperate with them as
friends but make our own laws and let's
take back control of our borders and put
in place an Australian style point
system so we can choose the quantity and
quality of who comes to Britain by doing
that we'll give ordinary working people
an even break Nick Clegg I think it's
pretty obvious that no one standing
here is going to win this election
outright so you're going to have to
choose like you did last time who's
going to have to work with whom I look
I'm not going to pretend that
everything's perfect though the country
is in a lot better shape now than it was
five years ago I'm not even going to
pretend that I haven't made mistakes I
have I put my hands up when I have and
I've learned from them
but what you will get from me and from
the Liberal Democrats is this the grit
and the resilience to finish the job of
balancing the books and doing so fairly
I will always act responsibly I'll never
let anyone else borrow money that we
don't have and jeopardize your wrists
your jobs and our economy and above all
I will always act fairly I won't let
anyone else in pose ideological cuts on
your hospitals and your schools and I
will always serve the whole of our
country not just parts of our country
the whole of our wonderful United
Kingdom little sturgeon this election is
a chance to change the Westminster
system so that it serves you better the
SMP will always stand up for Scotland's
best interests we will make Scotland's
voice here'd but I know that it's not
just people in Scotland to feel let down
by Westminster politics that's why my
message to people watching in England
Wales and Northern Ireland is one of
friendship I won't pretend I don't want
Scotland to be independent I do but as
long as Scotland remains part of the
Westminster system the SNP will seek to
work with others of like mind across the
UK to deliver positive change like many
of you we want an alternative to the
pain of austerity an end to the bedroom
tax a hope to the privatisation of the
NHS and we believe the scarce resources
of our countries should be invested in
the future of our children not in
nuclear weapons of what for the SNP is
of ought to make Scotland's voice here'd
but errors will also be a voice for new
better and progressive politics at
Westminster for all of us David Cameron
five years ago this country was on the
brink we had millions of people
unemployed and we had one of the biggest
budget deficits anywhere in the world
for the last five years we've been
working with the British people through
a long-term economic plan and that plan
is working there are almost two million
more people in work it's a balanced plan
so we've invested our in our NHS as well
as reducing the deficit and we've cut
taxes for 30 million working people and
the plans working because last year we
had the fastest growing economy of any
of the major Western countries now
tonight you're going to hear a lot of
people claiming a lot of things but
please remember these are the same
people who claimed that if we followed
our plan unemployment would go up that
the deficit wouldn't come down the
economy wouldn't grow that public
services would be destroyed they were
wrong then and they're wrong now the
choice at this election is sticking with
a plan that's working or going back to
the debt taxes borrowing and spending
that got us in this mess in the first
place I say let's not go back to square
one
Britain can do so much better than that
Leanne wood I'm speaking to everyone
back home in Wales tonight I'm from the
rambha and I understand all too well the
difficulties that have been faced by our
communities in recent years you tell me
that jobs and services have been cut to
the bone and that they can be cut no
more plaid Camry offers an alternative
we offer hope for a decent future for
our young people for thriving successful
communities in a Han parliament plight
Camry can win for Wales but we can only
do that with your support I'm asking you
to support plight come bury the party of
Wales to make our communities in Wales
as strong as they can be please support
plate Camry to make plate Camry where's
his voice in Westminster Ed Miliband
here's what I believe Britain succeeds
when working people succeed but that's
not the way it's been over the last five
years for five years wages haven't kept
up with bills for five years the NHS has
been going
backwards for five years our young
people have been fearing they'll have a
worse life than their parents it doesn't
have to be this way if I'm Prime
Minister I'll raise the minimum wage to
eight pounds an hour and ban
exploitative zero hours contract so we
reward hard work again in our country if
I'm Prime Minister I'll rescue our NHS
hiring more doctors and nurses if I'm
Prime Minister I'll build a future for
all of our young people saying to our
young people if you get the grades you
get an apprenticeship and cutting the
tuition fee from nine thousand to six
thousand pounds and we'll cut the
deficit every year and balance the books
some people will tell you tonight this
is as good as it gets for Britain I say
Britain could do so much better than
it's done over the last five years